[Musique]
et comment vont les choses entre john
nettoie
je n'étais
salut
le boulot s'est bien passé
mais je me sens un peu fatigué ces
derniers temps bats toi
[Musique]
vous avez tous les deux une vie bien
remplie il me paraît normal que tu te
sentes un peu fatigué mais ne t'inquiète
pas
moi aussi je me suis senti fatigué ces
derniers temps j'sais pas pourquoi
oui c'est ça
vous êtes allé au bar le rialto au jeune
public pas un truc vous avez bu deux
bières en attendant que votre petite
amie finisse un service et petit ami
votre petite amie et lena ka minsk
john c'est la première fois que je te
vois en plein jour on se bat ce soir
pourquoi est ce que tu m'as pas parler
d'elle rien dit car je savais avoir une
copine est contraire au règlement
tu doit la quitter je ne peux pas faire
ça il va falloir que tu me parles de
nous deux et si tu ne le fais pas je le
ferai
un seul corps pour plusieurs conscience
vous êtes vraiment différent et cela
vous êtes quoi
je fréquente son ancien petit à quand tu
dois le dire à john qu'est ce que tu
fais ci
tu m'explique
je n'aime pas quand vous êtes fâchés
tous les deux c'est important tu sais
que c'est grave
tu dois faire quelque chose je pensais
que tu étais celui qui s'épanouissait
mais j'avais tort
il faut que je te dise quelque chose je
viens mouren
johnatan